elle est parisienne mais c'est orléans
qu'elle a lancé son projet artistique
vous la connaissez sûrement elle
s'appelle mjc la grande gagnante de la
nouvelle star 2015 après orléans
meung-sur-loire et chez si elle se
produit à saint-jean-de-la-ruelle mj une
voix une belle énergie
une graine de star ça c'est sûr elle est
comme ça mj simple naturelle sympa quand
la république du centre lui a demandé
d'avoir un échange privilégié avec des
lecteurs en l'occurrence et lectrices
elle a dit oui sans hésiter c'est
intense mais je pense que ce soir
saint-jean ça va être encore plus
intense parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui t'attendent et je voulais savoir ton
ressenti par rapport à ça en fait je
suis très je suis très impatient de
cette date de ce soir parce qu'en plus
elles clôturent la mini tournée
qu'on a faites donc je suis très
impatient de retrouver un peu plus je
sais que le plu est hyper chaud enfin je
pense
quelques minutes avant le concert
mj se chauffer la voix pas très
longtemps
l'artiste a du métier cela se voit
car mj c'est d'abord une voix puissante
juste c'est aussi déjà une maîtrise de
la scène alors pour elle pas question de
renier la nouvelle star mais on sent
bien que la chanteuse veut faire autre
chose
je ne suis pas que la mj qui chante du
viaur quoi voilà ou du show must go nous
du gros sont comme ça j'aime la pop
j'aime la chanson française et j'espère
que les gens vont être surpris mais
agréablement surpris par ce qu'il va
arriver après
et après c'est un album en pleine
préparation il y aura cette chanson
poignées d'amour un hymne au drôle et
bienveillant petites imperfections du
corps
mj un drôle de parcours qui a commencé
dans le métro
2 c'est moi
cette journée passée dans le métro a été
très très très fondatrice en fait j'ai
rencontré des gens j'ai rencontré un
public qui a suivi après même ce que à
qui j'ai pas parlé directement qui
peut-être sont tombés devant leur
terrain de merde je les verrai public
s'est il ya donc je rien rien on a été
inutile dans toute cette démarche
alors forcément le concert de serge en
restera dans sa tête comme une page qui
se tourne
son histoire avec les musiciens de la
région centre où se termine
elles viennent signer avec universal je
suis enfin un garçon lucide sur lui
verser de plus viennent et auteur
compositeur interprète et barco grand
unisson pop sucrée romantisme et nous
régalera de son univers
le vent frais mo'kalamity fêter ce
qu'elle a bourges et c'est tant mieux
cette chanteuse de reggae viendra
présenter son nouvel album plus
militants que jamais foulé de meuf
dessous
tu es méchant
drôle d'installation à la collégiale du
pilier près de quatre mille personnages
de papier journal suspendu comment
s'interroger sur notre rapport à
internet
une installation signée bernard allain
brooks
et pour terminer petit tour à la galerie
vu lyon avec sauve qui peut toujours des
photos de grande qualité qui dénoncent
les atteintes à l'environnement est
toujours orléans le festival de jazz
revient à partir du 18 juin avec comme
tête d'affiché
andré manoukian un seul lieu cette année
le jardin de l'évêché et c'est gratuit